normal stream my name is Dan mcLaughlin
and I'm a nurse Family Partnership nurse
home visitor
it is a class issue and that is a large
reason as to why we focus on the
low-income families so that we can give
them a little bit of extra help a little
bit of extra knowledge because sometimes
it's the lack of knowledge that leads to
the mortality
my name is Stephanie and my son's name
is like
after legacy came she opened everything
like it was I'd literally call her for
everything like any question I had like
how much he should be but his
transitioning remote snaps and what I
should be doing like what if he gets
sick and she also helped me manage my
emotions I was a mom there's no way I
can prepare it's like you take so
hundred-and-some personal view raising
someone else it's a lot of
responsibility
amazingly proud of Stephanie and legacy
legacy when he was born these two pounds
13 ounces and now he was growing and
thriving and developing beautifully
you